at last you've got your grabby robot
hands on the long-awaited titanfall and
you're ready to run on some walls shoot
some faces and kick some butts though
you start off with some decent weaponry
things only get better as you diversify
your loadout options so here are some
tips to help you level up quickly and
get those unlocks start off by playing
campaign multiplayer the action is
pretty much the same as the standard
action in classic multiplayer but by
completing each side of the campaign
you'll unlock the ogre and Strider
chassis z' for use in your custom Titan
loadouts you can always use each chassis
and a preset loadout of course but you
want to be able to build your own beast
almost every match starts with the
running of the grunts AI soldier's flood
the field of battle and pilots swarm to
feed on the easy prey grunt inspector
kills earn you attrition points and
speed up your Titan build but they're
also tied to a lot of weapon attachment
unlocks like scopes and suppressors and
extended magazines and such check the
challenges for each bit of gear you want
to unlock and then focus on the
appropriate prey if you have the right
burn card select an amped version of the
weapon that you want to earn unlocks for
because it'll help you kill your quarry
more efficiently and it'll totally count
towards your unlock progress if however
you're just looking to farm grunts for
straight XP choose the preset assassin
class and rock the suppressed smart
pistol that thing is like industrial
farm equipment for harvesting grunts
weapon unlocks are important and can
make some guns like the longbow DMR
sniper much more versatile but in order
to unlock the weapons themselves you
need to focus on XP and nothing delivers
big XP bonuses like pilot kills at the
beginning of a match run to where your
friendly grunts are clustered find
yourself a nice cloak position or wall
hang and then ambush the enemy pilots
that come a-calling if you can equip a
suppressor you can extend your ambush
longer by remaining hidden on the radar
if you score the first kill of the match
you'll get an XP bonus and because many
pilots use burn cards during their
initial deployment odds are you'll also
get an XP bonus for canceling set burn
card
speaking of which get in the habit of
using your burn cards you can only have
25 in your deck at a time and they fill
up quickly if you aren't using a few
each match use rare ones early on to
gain access to abilities your enemies
haven't unlocked yet like the active
radar pulse also known as the you neon
skeleton disco dance party
[Music]
now let's talk Titans if you're working
on your weapon attachment unlocks and
you want to stick to playing the pilot
don't let your Titan languish unbuilt
bring down your auto Titan and set it to
guard a slightly out-of-the-way area
it'll probably score some grunt kills
and off a pilot if you're lucky
alternatively set it to follow you then
listen for when it tells you that it's
engaging enemy pilots and Titans and
spring into action just don't do this
during close attrition matches as auto
Titans are pretty easy kills that will
boost your enemies attrition score
significantly and hinder your chances of
getting bonus xp for winning the match
if you can be one of the first to call
down your Titan in a match
perhaps by using burn cards be sure to
equip the chain gun the accuracy and
range makes it great for picking off
pilots who are moving quickly or perched
on rooftops it works well on grunts too
though stomping on the poor suckers is
just as effective and lets you stay on
the lookout for would-be rodeo riders
when you're playing as a pilot get in
the habit of taking potshots at Titans
that are in combat even if it's risky or
your priorities lie elsewhere you're
basically signing up for free assist XP
when that Titan gets doomed
also don't underestimate the
disorienting power of arc grenades
they're great for setting up a rodeo on
an enemy Titan infiltrating an enemy
occupied hard point or just ambushing
pilots who are unawares and finally if
you happen to pass one of these heavy
turrets on the map take a few seconds to
hack it to your side you'll get a neat
little XP bonus the hits it lands will
reduce your Titan build time and it'll
probably attract enemy pilots looking
for some quick XP who you can then
proceed to murder eyes check the
comments below for bonus tips and
strategies and add a few of your own and
happy Titan falling
[Music]